you just wrapped a movie I think days
ago with one of my favorite characters
of all time Arnold Schwarzenegger yes
[Applause]
you know what I always do I forget he's
in these commercials now for that video
game have you seen a video game yeah the
video game where he's dressed as a
general he's like get the troops ready
and I forget that he was the governor of
California
he was but what's he like he was awesome
my husband is directing this film he
wrote it and he's starring in it and
Arnold was kind enough to be a part of
it and um he was awesome I mean my
husband's a first-time director and he
was Arnold was so kind and listened to
him right and was very funny it's an
it's a it's an action comedy so it's
nice to see him doing some more he is a
funny guy in the past when he
interviewed him he's very I was like oh
yes and I've always heard he was funny
I've heard that he likes he loves to
like mention his catch phrases from all
of his movies most people would be like
oh my God I don't want to do that but
they're really cool I don't want to do
that fair is that true that he does that
I didn't have that experience with him I
wish I did because that would be amazing
I've had friends tell me that he'd be
like well I gotta go to the bathroom
I'll be back
everyone's like that's really good and
then he's like I'm gonna go get a muffin
I'll be back
all right you did that uh no just the
only time that he did like he did this
really cool move which was when we were
setting up a shot and we were all kind
of waiting for a while he'd just go and
and then that meant we should go right
we start rolling right he's had this
power just to be like and you're like
Arnold is saying we're gonna go we're
gonna go uh yes and And So It Begins
you do a good Arnold I one of my
favorite encounters with a celebrity
ever was years ago I'm in a coffee shop
it's early in the morning I'm really
tired I haven't woken up yet and I get
my cup of coffee and it's in I'm in
Manhattan we're doing the Late Night
show there and all of a sudden I
realized there's someone waiting to get
his coffin I look over and just then
Arnold Schwarzenegger looks down at me
and we're looking at each other and he
goes well you know he knew me and I'd
interview you yeah yeah yeah he just
goes like I go like oh hi how you doing
how are you and I went good to see you
and then we had nothing to say to each
other and you can tell it's early and
both of us are trying to think and
Arnold's thinking and then he just looks
at me and he goes off in the morning is
good
and I said yeah no coffee it helps it's
good and then there was a pause and he
looked at me he went helps wake you up
the best coffee commercial I've ever
really good now uh speaking of
incredibly famous people on this planet
your co-star in the new Jack Reacher
film Mr Tom Cruise yes you on Twitter
you call him Tommy to Tommy Tommy Tommy
on Twitter you called him Tommy on
Twitter and I was thinking you don't do
that to his face do you yes
he's the best he's the best yes we just
we shot this movie and we got along so
well and he is the nicest man the nicest
man so I feel like I can call him Tommy
I haven't heard that that it's not okay
to call him Tommy it's not okay there's
from you okay now I don't know
grave mistake main Robots coming to get
you